let's get dark with it i don't know
let's let's let's go pessimistic we have
the story from harvard.edu harvard youth
poll finds young americans are worried
about democracy and even fearful of
civil war oh you know i'd love to say it
they say more than half of young
americans feel democracy and the country
is under threat and over a third think
they may see a second u.s civil war
within their lifetimes according to the
42nd harvard youth poll released by
harvard kennedy schools institute of
politics the poll also found approval
for president biden has plummeted and a
majority of respondents are unhappy with
how the president and congress are doing
their jobs i think it's funny that
you're asking young people it's like how
do you feel about congress and they're
like well i've realized they're bad it's
like it's because you're getting older
and you're watching them but older
people have been watching them for a
long time knowing they're bad i love
that joe biden's approval rating is
tanking but i knew who joe biden was
back during occupy wall street 10 years
ago all these young people are like kind
of feel like i was lied to about joe
budden but we've got this other one that
wraps along with it hedge fund founder
ray dalio predicts there is a 30 chance
of u.s civil war in the next 10 years
because of emotional political
polarization believes the constitution
may save the nation
now
i think the issue is there's two
realities and i think you know most
people we talk to agree certainly some
people say no it's not true but i think
if you talk to um
you talk to some of these these
democrats they'll tell you russiagate
still happened like even though we know
and we've known for years trump did not
collude with russia they still believe
it things like that if you have people
who uh we had an article from slate the
uh no salon i'm sorry salon the other
day yeah that said the second civil war
may come like which side are you on
choose your side now and they said
that our multi-racial democracy is
anathema to the republican party or like
the republican view
and i'm like that's insane republicans
are not that that is not what they are
but if you have people who live in that
world
then yeah i i agree we're heading in
that direction and it's not just my
opinion it's the opinion of a guy who a
hedge fund founder whose job is
literally to make predictions about
where these markets are going to go and
he thinks there's a good chance it could
happen now we should right away say okay
what do we mean by civil war
yeah oh i think we're in one already and
what i mean by that is it's a fourth and
fifth generational war which is
propaganda information warfare economic
warfare so we have had ground skirmishes
we've had we've had antifa fighting with
proud boys we had right-wing groups
clashing with left-wing groups we've had
um insurgency there was a guy who showed
up to a nice facility with a ghost gun
and some fire bombs there was a dude who
went and executed a trump supporter in
the middle of the street in portland a
lot of things like that this is a
congressional baseball game that was
shot up as well that's right yeah that's
right yeah and so that was a bernie
volunteer who did that and um steve
scalise almost lost his life i could see
like a corporate uh war like the
corporations versus everybody else and
that happening in the united states is
like a battleground for it unfortunately
that's already happening but like a hot
war that the corporations have like
private military and but where would
they
locate their bases they have their
corporate headquarters they could use
they probably own a lot of land that
they would use
i don't i don't i don't but other than
that i don't see the american people
going out corporations are not
ideological for the most part they're
being infiltrated by ideological
individuals schwab is the ideologue but
he's he's something far beyond just a
corporation he's davos group he wants
corporations to run the world i think
we're living in a world where ideas are
more powerful than bullets and i think
those ideas and that kind of form of
manipulation is something that has been
used already in a war that we don't even
know exist right now that has hurt
tremendously the populations of this
world and i think i think this guy is is
right i think his assessment is fair but
i think it's going to hedge more on the
prominence of social media so if social
media is as prominent and becomes more
prominent in our lives i do believe the
likelihood of civil war is going to go
up if social media becomes less
prominent it's not going to be as
prominent that's what i personally
believe because when we look at big tech
algorithms when we look at the
prominence of social media you see hyper
polarization of people on the political
spectrum going into their echo chambers
more and more and more and the algorithm
regurgitates it and i think deliberately
pushes it this is my own theory towards
a divide and conquer agenda that has
people fighting each other rather than
looking at the true source of their
problems that's really creating it
that's my personal perspective and
opinion but if we get rid of social
media now i'm not saying get rid of it
i'm saying the prominence social media
becomes more prominent so so look our
show is
prominence of social media that people
choose to go to youtube or twitter or
facebook wherever else to get content
they find channels like ours we're not
on tv
so certainly this is what big tech big
the big machine the establishment wants
they want to homogenize everything they
have slowly been removing people from
youtube and if you search on youtube for
news what are you going to get if you if
you typed in like you know
something like germany uh unvaxed
lockdown you ain't going to get us
you're not going to get my channels tim
cast tim castnews tim castaire ain't
gonna happen you're gonna get cnn abc
nbc msnbc et cetera even though we know
they lie
we still have joe rogan as the number
one show on spotify like which we just
saw there's an appetite people can go
find their shows that they want and
that's good for now well but as far as
the civil war though just to chime in
like we hear civil war we think of 1861
right we we have as americans it was the
most pivotal moment in our history maybe
more so than even independence it's um
it's ingrained in our fiber in our
history um we're not gonna see that i i
don't think that's you know so we might
have a civil war it's not gonna look
like that um i like to think i might
have mentioned this to lydia earlier i
like to think of it maybe as is a brexit
right um that we just you know like we
might say
this isn't working out and you know like
trying to maybe rule like from
washington dc a bunch of corrupt
politicians
where our our words are the law and
we're gonna rule the whole nation which
is very diverse by the way we have
different cultures different people
different traditions they
trying to to to govern everybody under
one umbrella to me doesn't make a lot of
sense anymore i think the framers would
say yeah you know this isn't working um
i think they'd look and say you know
what what is the purpose of government
it's to protect life liberty and
property that government's really not
doing that anymore i think some of them
might say that yeah it got out of hand
the representatives they used to
represent i don't know a few thousand
people thirty thousand and now i don't
know seven hundred thousand fifty seven
hundred fifty thousand people one guy's
supposed to represent you can barely
represent yourself effectively uh that's
your number one job so i think
democratic republicanism is is dying and
and we need a new form where you can't
have republics uh you can't have these
people that get voted in and then get
bribed that's it over and over and over
and whether it's a new face or an old
face they're getting money from exxon
and all these crazy corporations
alphabet pfizer pfizer and it's like a
it's like a it's like a point of
weakness of vulnerability in the system
these these bribes that keep happening
it wouldn't matter though right if the
politicians didn't have the power they
have
um like all those bribes do they happen
because there's so much at stake because
they have so much power if we remove the
power from the politicians
that's much less of a problem and and we
have a mechanism to do that we have you
know
if you look in in recent history it's
not just brexit other places have said
you know what this isn't working um and
for i think for americans that's a
really hard idea i don't think we're
close to that idea but you know at fe
our motto anything peaceful right and
and if we just you know like as
americans say
you know we had a good run the marriage
it's not really working out you go your
way we're gonna go our way and if if
people in it's not i'm not saying that's
practical i think it's it's very painful
i think it would be hard but but i i
think that approach
makes sense i so we've had the
conversation about peaceful divorce or
national divorce quite a bit but i think
a lot of people who are proponents of
this don't understand that like
california for instance their their
southern california is completely
dependent upon the colorado river so if
we all start going our separate ways and
california's blue and they break off
colorado is going to be like you know
what we're going to you know you want
our water let's let's negotiate we're no
longer part of the same system and it's
going to change things they could cut
them off they could start polluting you
know upstream california might get mad
you've got states that think they have a
right to the great lakes let's talk
about you know pennsylvania the fracking
fields the amount of energy they produce
in in western pennsylvania well the
surrounding states need that energy all
of a sudden they break off and the trade
how is it going to function what are the
rules with the laws like we're seeing
with brexit i'm not saying it's it's an
it's it's the bad outweighs the good i'm
just saying what i think might end up
happening is you've got eastern oregon
wanting to break away from western
oregon
western oregon won't allow that they're
wealthy they're powerful that's the
center of power and the people in the
east they pay them they're effectively
the serfs in the in the fields they're
not going to let them go so the question
i guess is
if we do see national divorce
do you think that the the overwhelmingly
dense
deep red areas within a blue state will
just be like guess we're going with the
far left on this one or they're going to
be like no way
if if the if the republican red state
conservative independent libertarian
whatever group is breaking away we want
to join them well you're surrounded by
blue states you may be southern illinois
completely red
but too many too much blue all around
you what do you do no fighting starts it
would be messy like if you i brought up
the american civil war earlier that was
kind of clean even though there's a lot
of bloodshed in the fact that you had a
one boundary right you had the
mason-dixon line and i know that there
were some states that weren't
necessarily of the south north of that
but that's not the point today we have
different divides um and
it's
you know some of it's urban rural right
like so so this wouldn't be easy it
would be messy um and you bring up a lot
of as far as trade water rights mineral
rights um all of that you know but it's
preferable i think to either a real war
a real civil war or living under a
government that's increasingly
tyrannical and that's what i see but it
precipitates war
so you have you know upstate new york a
lot of which is more conservative more
libertarian you know not interested in
what the new york city is doing and
let's say they uh that you know people
the overwhelming majority of people in
upstate new york are like nah you're in
new jersey i don't know what you're
doing so you're out because it's urban
versus rural you think like new york is
just gonna be like i guess we'll die no
they're gonna be like you can't do this
open the roads up you can't id us we're
in new york and then
it's not instant if there was some kind
of you know convention of states and
then everyone said okay that's it we're
breaking up and then we'll negotiate how
this goes eastern oregon is going to be
like no and what are they going to do
are they going to come in if look if
eastern oregon is faced with the
possibility of the country breaking
apart they'll immediately be like we're
with them and oregon and washington and
these states are going to be like nah
but then they're backed up by idaho what
happens when the food isn't coming what
happens when california which produces a
large amount of food for this country
all of a sudden is under completely
different rules that and then what
happens if the overwhelmingly leftists
go uh in the government start seizing
land and pulling off stupid bs
worst case scenario we get invaded by an
external force and then the history book
writes it as that was the moment the u.s
was destroyed
you're not the first person that brought
that up i think that's an overblown fear
i think nothing would unite americans
more than an international forest trying
to you know get in our backyard um
you know as far as like an example like
oregon the good thing is there are even
i i'm not usually somebody that quotes
international precedent but we do have
ever you know right to the u.n
people have a right to declare
independence and if if people over there
decide you know what this isn't working
out we there are steps to take to do
that like i said i don't think we're
there right now i think americans have
to go they must they're gonna have to be
pushed much further
but when i look at the long-term picture
of things and i've never talked about
this publicly just you know stuff you
chew on in the shower or something like
like this isn't really working out like
like what what's in it what's the
off-ramp where is it well this is
something that i was talking about last
year when i first came on the show one
of the first things i brought up was
peaceful divorce we need a peaceful
divorce and we need more memes uh in the
larger spectrum if you remember the
first episode that's what i was kind of
going on about but we have to remember
there's two factors here one the state
is becoming more and more sociopathic
they don't only just want their pound of
flesh where they literally create ideas
like civil asset forfeiture which is
insane but they want to tax you they
want to regulate you they want to
control every aspect of your existence
towards a crazy maniacal level and
throughout human history communists have
never peacefully allowed separation they
have wanted to control everything in
every aspect of your existence and it's
sick and it's twisted and it totally
destroys any form of progress but there
are instances just like with the amish
where people do come together and say
this is crazy i don't want to be a part
of this and they are respected as their
own individual entity which i believe
individuals and groups like the free
state project are trying to make their
own kind of amish group in new hampshire
and i think what they're doing is is
amazing i think they have a lot of
success stories and i think it is
possible on that small micro level but i
think what's really going to be likely
is that economically financially
socially
there's going to be a huge storm coming
and when that storm comes people are
going to come together and they're going
to live together and that's going to be
their own individual groups and they're
going to be identified as their own
power structures i think that is way
more likely and there might be clashes
between power structures and that might
be deemed a civil war but i think that
is more of a likely situation than one
of the old kind of knowledge the north
versus the south which is impractical
and if we look at historically other
civil wars it's not just territorial
regions it's people fighting over ideas
and i think that's that's going to
happen on on many levels when everything
hits the fan and this is the real
uh i think the potential catalyst we
have is
i don't know which side has a stronger
moral stance you have the left and
wokism which is a non-theistic religion
or cult whatever to call it and these
people are willing to burn down and
murder they've burned down buildings 25
people dead in the george floyd riots
and when aaron danielson is shot in the
chest in portland they cheered for more
than one occasion
so these people celebrate the death of
their perceived enemies now the right
doesn't do that they're
not and there's still a strong moral
position and that's abortion
so i wonder you know what we saw in 1861
was a strong moral position that was a
strong catalyst for the war slavery
abolitionists were like we will storm in
full speed to end this
with
woke-ism
there come they're going around saying
white supremacy they're they're they're
doing rallies right now where they claim
that white supremacy is defending itself
with kyle written house and all that
stuff but you also have right now the
supreme court issuing or i'm sorry
hearing there or hearing the oral
arguments on the mississippi 15-week
abortion ban and a belief among many in
the media and many leftists that come
june 2022 abortion will be banned that
will ignite
insanity among the left
and the right will absolutely stand by
to defend it with these trigger laws
happening with blue states then
reinforcing you're gonna have a hard
ideological divide between woke and
unwoke and that could be a potential
catalyst or at the very least
if we're talking about you know tinder
being thrown into the fire and the
flames slowly getting bigger june 2020
if the supreme court does overturn roe v
wade it'll be like someone just threw a
whole drum of gasoline right on top of
it it doesn't mean it'll spark a war it
just means it's going to get hot
yeah no there will be a lot of fury and
anger and gnashing of teeth might but i
will say my prediction is um i do think
it will happen i don't think it'll be no
this is a bold prediction no boy i don't
think it'll be as big of a deal as you
think the civil war
roe v wade yeah i if they overturn roe v
versus wade um it it'll be
we'll talk about it a lot there'll be
like i said gnashing of teeth
but we've we've been here for so long um
i i think it's going to be
it's going to make social media crazy i
don't think it's going to be like what
we saw in 2020 uh and that's my hope so
you think we're on the back end we're
heading down now things are going to
slow down and even yeah if you look
across demographics um i think i think
abortion is kind of a losing battle for
um for democrats i think progressives
hold to it religiously um but you know
like they're gonna they're gonna get
really loud and angry about it but
they're not the people that are gonna
get most loud and angry aren't the
people that are going to go march in
streets over it well they'll march don't
get me wrong they'll march um but
they're not the people that are going to
light up cars and and do that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you